BACK AGAINST AMERICAN
SURVEILLANCE AND THIS WAS A
DANGEROUS MANEUVER.
THESE PICTURES TAKEN SHOW JUST
HOW CLOSE THE CHINESE FIGHTER
JET CAME.
CLOSE ENOUGH FOR THE AMERICANS
TO SEE DETAILS ON THE CHINESE
CRAFT AND THE PILOT INSIDE.
>> IT'S DIFFICULT TO SAY WITH
PRECISION, BUT WITHIN 30 FEET.
OF THE P-8.
VERY, VERY CLOSE.
VERY DANGEROUS.
>> Reporter: IT DIDN'T HAPPEN
JUST ONCE.
AS THE AMERICAN PLANE FLEW ON A
ROUTINE PATROL MISSION
REPEATEDLY THE CHINESE FIGHTER
ROARED OVER, UNDER, AND BESIDE
IT.
>> IT WAS UNDER TO MAKE A POINT
OF SHOWING ITS WEAPONS.
>> Reporter: THE INCIDENT
OCCURRED IN INTERNATIONAL AIR
SPACE 135 MILES EAST OFF THE
SOUTH COAST OF CHINA.
AMERICA AND ITS ALLIES ARE
CLASHING WITH THE RUSSIAS AND
CHINESE OVER SURVEILLANCE IN THE
REGION.
THE U.S. MOVED TWO LARGE DRONES
TO JAPAN.
THEY ARE CALLED GLOBAL HAWKS AND
ARE USED FOR SURVEILLANCE AND
NORTH OF JAPAN, A RUSSIA JET
BUZZED ANOTHER U.S. PLANE
DESIGNED TO TRACK RADAR SIGNALS.
THE PILOT CAME WITHIN 100 FEET
AND FLASHED HIS WEAPONS AT THE
AMERICAN PLANE.
THE U.S. OFFICIALS SEE A PATTERN
OF PUSHBACKS CONTINUING WITH
THIS MORE RECENT ENCOUNTER.
>> OBVIOUSLY, A DEEPLY